everybody who's ever invested in me has
told me no
everybody i nobody has rolled over and
said absolutely let's do it it's it's
always come from people who have said no
if the filmmaker's going to raise money
and we should just probably pick some
ballpark figure so maybe 500 000
okay
how can a filmmaker mitigate risk
i think when when putting together
you know a half a million dollar budget
the best way to mitigate risk on that is
to think about genre think about star
power
um you know as i as i try to tell a lot
of producers you know
if you
if you're only thinking about what the
public perception is of your work and
the stars that you are working with is
your end game
you're not never going to be happy
you know
be smart in your casting you know just
because
somebody is not a-list studio powerhouse
player today doesn't mean they weren't
5-10 years ago doesn't mean somebody
isn't on three television series that
are syndicating around the globe you
know two or three times a day in 140
different countries those actors are
gold and they're not expensive so you
know when when we when we cast our films
it's about familiar faces it's about
people with good reputation people that
we enjoy being with 18 hours a day
anyway right but i think from mitigating
risk it's about it's about getting
actors that people recognize
and people can say oh i remember this
actor from that series or this series or
that show or that film
and you know
it's when you're working in a half a
million dollars it's really not a lot of
money it goes fast
and you know to be able to put
you know maybe 35 40 of that above the
line i think is is smart and then you
know you you got your your crew and all
below the line you know make sure that's
an efficient team that makes your
product look and sound good
get good editors do whatever you have to
do to make the product look as good as
it can i mean you can make that that
money go a long way if you know how to
do it
but
again it comes down to content a five
hundred thousand dollar drama
without the right cast is not the same
thing as a 300 000 action film with just
one or two right people in it i mean
there they can be completely different
success
so
i always think you know it goes back to
really understanding globally what your
product
how how products of that budget and that
level and similar cast do it's really
important to look at like films i mean
as filmmakers again it goes back to
thinking everything we do is so special
we're going to knock the world on its
ass because this is just the best script
ever and it's going to be the best movie
ever
i always say you know always go in under
promise over deliver you know and i
think that's the biggest problem with
you know a lot of the pitch decks that
we look at that come through
everybody's got names and faces on these
things they're never going to acquire
and they comp it to films they're not
even ever going to come close to comping
with they always pick the big grand slam
films
and and what i try to teach producers is
that when you go in with all these
promises and hype
you're going to start casting your film
and you're going to have two strikes
against you when your your investor says
well who's in it and you didn't get
the names of the faces that were in your
pitch deck
and you know
i think that a lot of people go in such
high expectations and they get reality
check sure you're going to get the
occasional like wow i can't believe we
got this person or that person
but you know
when when you're pitching to investors i
always say let's just remember the
investors are smarter than we are we're
going to them for money because they are
successful at doing things and it's very
similar to real estate if somebody came
to you and said i want you to put 500
grand into this housing project and
within 16 months you're going to make 20
million dollars you probably wouldn't
invest
especially with an accredited builder
developer or somebody that you know and
see the track record that okay their
half million dollars turns into 20
million within a year and a half and a
lot of filmmakers go in with that kind
of pomp and circumstance what i like to
do when i pitch investors is i i use
films that most people haven't heard of
is comps where i say hey this film was
made for 500 grand it made back 3
million
this film was made for 600 grand it made
back 7 million because i'm not going to
compare it to blair witch i'm not going
to compare it to napoleon dynamite those
are sh th that stuff's all lightning in
a bottle and and good on them there's
nothing no ding against them it's just
that's reality and investors sniff that
bs a mile away i think the most
important thing when you're pitching
people for money is is you go and you
make the film as low as you can because
the first thing an investor always wants
to know is how much money are you
getting paid you know we talked about
that in some of our earlier interviews i
think how much do you pay yourself or
what shouldn't it what should you be
paid
and you know the old saying is the the
producer is always the first one to buy
lunch and the last to get paid right
i think investors like to see you're not
lining your pockets
they want to know you have certain skin
in the game and when you go to them and
you say look you're 500 000 investment
if we place it here here and here with
this star power could generate two to
five million dollars over the next three
to five years
all of a sudden they don't feel they're
getting a snow job and that's that's the
reality of our business and that's if
you're doing well so
i think what's really important is it's
you know you ask about finding the sweet
spot on budget i think it's about
i think you always have to put your
investor first because a lot of people
just want to get one movie made and they
figure they're going to move on to the
next and where we've been very
successful is having a track record with
with investors you know we don't do
one-off investors we work with the same
people over and over again and that
comes from trust it comes from
delivering it comes from putting a
product on the screen that they could be
proud of when it's done
and and having success globally and it
takes time nothing happens like that
you know and and that's i think the
problem is is all these pitch decks that
come in are just lined with bs and fluff
and hype
and i think if people just take a step
back and kind of do a reality check and
what they're presenting i think they'd
be a lot more successful in getting
funds it's just about honesty and
integrity
and you said also not just the images
and in the pitch text but also shooting
something like a scene that goes so much
further than i i i look at some of these
pocs that people shoot and they just
look they look so good i i've never been
impressed with the pitch deck and it's
just littered it's littered with
[ __ ] i i just got sent a 60-page
pitch deck
that i i'm consulting a producer on next
week he sent it to me
i shot holes in 95 of it and they spent
a lot of money getting this pitch deck
made it is useless and it's really
unfortunate because i see it all the
time and it's it's not that i have all
the answers
i've raised a lot of money from private
equity that's what i do i know when they
know they're getting bs and i know what
not to do and these pitch decks are just
constantly just
just filled with so much information
it's paperweight that they don't need
you know less i'm a big i'm a big
proponent of less is more in the room
i talk about it in the book uh the first
time i ever raised private equity i went
into a very successful businessman's
office got took three months to get the
meeting i brought in a briefcase filled
with scripts budgets you know we didn't
have the term pitch deck back then but
head shots and you know what we're gonna
do and all the projections and the ask
and takes from the distributors and all
the people that wanted to sign on
and i literally i literally broke out
this this kinkos box if you guys
remember what that is kinko's you know i
think it's fedex printers now i broke
out a box and a guy said stop
what are you giving me i said oh i have
a script i have a budget he said look
around my office and cornered a corner
of his grand office there was stacks of
paper
knee to hip high all over the place
there's just paper and he said these are
all proposals from people that want
money from me he said you want to end up
in a pile give me your paperwork
why don't we just sit here and have a
conversation you tell me what it is you
want to do how much money you need how
long is it going to take for me to start
seeing a return what are you going to do
with it
and we were able to have a conversation
bang bang bang
and that's that's how our our funding
comes it's not with pitch decks it's not
with
reels it's not with anything other than
just eye contact and honesty and
integrity
most of our outlines when we when we
meet with investors is three to five
pages tops they're really small and it's
just it's just facts here you go
so then where where is the idea of of
these elaborate pitch decks come from oh
i think it's brilliant i think somebody
came up with the idea that they make a
lot of money getting them from
filmmakers to build a pitch deck i don't
know
and i'm sure they work i know there are
platforms that do seminars on pitch
decks and i'm sure they work for people
i'm not saying they don't work for
everybody
i just know that i see my share of them
because a lot of people send them in and
say hey will you give me your thoughts
on this pitch deck and they are just
loaded with [ __ ]
and i i really believe less is more it's
you know two plus two's got to equal
four in an investor's mind a lot of
people that you go to for money have
been pitched everything you know and
they they pay business managers and
accountants a lot of money to protect
them and they're all told the same thing
don't invest in the music industry the
film industry nightclubs or restaurants
right that's like the first thing when
you get money you're told what not to do
so you already go in with a strike
against you when you meet with an
investor
and they've seen it all they've heard it
all and they know
that they have the ability to make your
dreams come true by just saying the
three-letter word yes
and i think speaking too much in the
room is wrong i think
you know even a fool is considered wise
when they're quiet
wait for questions to be asked stay on
point
don't over analyze everything i've seen
more deals get killed in a room because
a potential investor will ask a question
and there's a 30-minute answer i know
i'm long-winded that's my nature but in
the room it's a whole different ball
game yes no
if they ask for something you tell them
how it's going to be and you shut your
mouth
and
you know people ruin their own deals
time and time again with too much
information and you know as i talk about
in the book don't be afraid to say i
don't know one of the greatest most
fruitful relationships i ever had with a
with an investor came from saying i
don't know
he asked me a question i didn't know the
answer and i said sir i don't know but
i'll find out for you
and what that did is allowed me an
excuse to contact them again in a day or
two with the answer to the question they
wanted to know and i called them back i
got them through their secretary he got
on the phone he said yeah what do you
want and i said look really enjoyed our
time together a couple days ago you
asked me a question i didn't have the
answer and he said i did i said yeah i
told him this was your question this is
the answer he said i got to tell you
something after you left my attorney and
i
we enjoyed our meeting with you we made
fun of you in some respect but at your
expense you know that happens we make
fun of everybody who comes in and tap
dances for money
he said but we we were really moved by
the fact that you said you didn't know
the answer to something because it
showed us that you're willing to say you
don't know you were willing to be honest
enough not to bs your way out of it and
you took the time to find out he said
well listen i appreciate the information
i'm going to let you know right now i'm
just going to say yes to your proposal
let's move forward and do it
that wound up being like a
financial relationship that went on for
for i don't know how many films and how
many years
and that's that was birthed out of just
saying i don't know
so
you know when it comes to trying to
raise private equity
um it's important to remember these
people are smarter than you and they've
heard it all and and i they they can
usually smell right through the bs
you know
they cut to the chase with them
they know why you're there
but when they said they made fun of you
did they tell you what some of the
things were like oh eventually they did
you know well you know you get nervous
you know when you're you're tap dancing
for for your next meal you know you
sometimes you tremble sometimes you say
things wrong i think i spilled water on
their coffee table not anything but they
gave me a glass of water and i think i
was reaching for something and i spilled
and it was you know i was nervous it's
like my first it was my first attempt at
getting capital i was scared
it seems forgivable but yeah okay yeah
it was funny to them
[Laughter]
i guess so let's see the the indie guy
squirm yeah oh my god and you know
what's funny is
you know what happens i'll tell you i'll
tell you something you know we talk
about money i've had investors call back
when you know they don't always say yes
and they said why do you need so much
money you know people are making movies
on a dime now it seems it doesn't seem
like you're blowing stuff up you're not
you know hanging off the empire state
building why do you need so much money
investors are getting more and more
savvy about what things really cost
they become very wise to it there's just
so much information at their fingertips
now the people that they surround
themselves with they they are paid to
investigate and know what things really
cost you know the days of going into
people and asking for millions of
dollars or getting further and further i
mean there are those rare exceptions but
i think you also have to be really savvy
on on an investor's ability
you know keep in mind what you know just
because somebody's rich doesn't mean
they can just roll over and write you
millions of dollars in checks you know
you don't know what their overhead is
their exposure is what other
responsibilities they have what tax
needs they have or have to avoid
so you know i think it's really
important to if somebody is is
introducing you to somebody that is a
potential investor you need to do your
research
if somebody is saying i want to i want
to introduce you to somebody they could
be a potential investor take the time to
say what do they do
what is their family size what are they
you know they got houses all over the
world are they they live a modest
lifestyle are they flashy find out
research them you know google's a
wonderful thing find out some of the
things that have happened in their life
their successes and their failures make
sure they haven't had family tragedies
that is your project may remind them of
and i'm a firm believer whenever you go
into the room to pitch somebody whether
it's an independent financier or it's a
studio always have two or three projects
under your belt or under your your arm
because you may say something and start
down the road of a project and they can
say yeah no no no we're not interested
we don't want to make film like that or
we're not interested we develop
something like that it didn't work
you know you wait two or three months to
get a meeting with somebody and they
tell you in the first two sentences of
your pitch this isn't going to work for
them that meeting is either over or you
can say okay respectfully understood put
it away pull out another project
so if they're accountants let's suppose
these are not
quote-unquote film people these usually
are okay so so they're people that have
made money in other um industries and
their accountants or business managers
to tell them stay away from the
following things which include making a
film
why do you think they would even say yes
um
well i think there are people that
haven't been told that or if they have
um they're still open to it you know
i i will be
i i would say that most of the people
that i have been fortunate enough to do
business with have said to me early in a
relationship
don't ever ask me to fund a film i would
never do that
and you know you look at it you say well
okay but people who are doing films are
doing very well if they're if they're
done properly and the model is done and
the budget's safe and the output
justifies the investment and there's
also so many incentives to investors
that they're not even aware of whether
it's the write-offs that they can get
and again i always say talk to your
accountant every situation is different
everybody's tax situation is different
every state has different laws and you
know there's different things that need
to be considered but there have been
bills put into place you know like the
jobs act that'll and bless an investor
for investing in a film there are also
investors that have companies that if
you can justifiably
involve that company that they own in
the advertisement aspect that they can
actually get
that film's investment written off as an
advertisement expense and it can do that
you know long-term depreciation
i've even had investors say to me you
know don't don't pay us any money back
right now we're taking a hit on this for
a while for the company
you got to slow the roll on some of
these returns i mean that does happen
everybody's situation is different
but
um there's the reality of you know when
people make big money and a lot of
things are accessible on what people
make or how successful they are i always
say cut those numbers in half they're
all you know fabricated or they're
pre-tax dollars and people have you know
people at that level are pretty
responsible usually
especially if they've been around a long
time and they come from older money that
they didn't just make it yesterday
uh by picking magic six numbers um
you know you really have to go in and
just because somebody's worth a hundred
million dollars it doesn't mean you ask
for 10 or doesn't mean you ask for one
you know why don't you start small and
gain their trust have a base hit or a
double
and then they can go back and say what
else do you want to do and so we'll have
this other project we'd like to do the
budget's a little higher than last time
and if you've had success you're not
going to have an issue with it
i've learned some from some people that
are very close to me that have had a lot
of success that
they're successful because of what they
say yes and no to you know smart people
in development or in real estate
they'll make they'll make a move on a
piece of property
and they look at it and say can i make
3x on this in 24 to 32 months
and if the answer is no they don't buy
the property so as a filmmaker you can't
guarantee that
so what is your pitch going to be what
is your angle going to be and that's how
a lot of savvy investors think
and then it goes back to the bs and the
fluff on a pitch deck trying to appeal
to that mindset and you know nine times
out of nine you're not going to fulfill
those promises so you have to be very
careful in your presentation you know
some of our investors said look
i know you don't want to hear this
you come off a 30 million dollar studio
film you you can do something with a
hundred grand show what you do with a
hundred grand
that makes sense
we'll move on we'll get bigger and
bigger sometimes you gotta come back and
say look with that hundred grand you're
not going to have the success you're
going to hope to see because with that
money you're offering we can't get the
star that's going to move this over the
hump so can you come up to 150 give me
another 50 grand so i can get this actor
or that actor and i'll show you what i
can do for the 100 plus the talent side
and then we can have a conversation and
often they'll say oh okay i understand
how that works now and they'll start
working with you on that
you've got to be open and fluid and
those doors should never be closed i've
had everybody who's ever invested in me
has told me no
everybody i nobody has rolled over and
said absolutely let's do it it's it's
always come from people who have said no
right as the first absolutely even even
the gentleman who financed my first film
wasn't the first time i've come to him
for money
yeah it took five years to get them to
do it
so it did yeah it's always been those
everybody i've everybody i've been
blessed enough to be backed by has
started with with seasons of nos or just
don't don't come to me for film i don't
want to do it